bro I feel like we've had to re-record
this twitch video like four times
because there's always a new
update so initially we covered it cuz we
we just caught wind of the the booby
streams all the way from twitch we got a
new meta that's begun what is that
game I never heard of
[Music]
it
yo
sorry I like this
[Music]
[Applause]
song so that's the meta just her no caps
and just the boobs and that's it yeah
that's the next level of the [__] and
she's not playing she's just playing
footage of a video game yes of course
okay cuz we always we know that
[__] back then people didn't
care about them playing they just they
just looking at the girl how nice she is
everything and stuff and it would make
they would so that's just the next level
they don't care about the plane okay
it's just a girl a pretext to have a
girl there yeah that's it mhm for for
for What specifically what you talking
about she looking good for for for for
twitch for whatever got you okay she's
not showing any nudity but just like got
you
yep
I love this game too that's why I put it
I was like okay this game is this should
be a game that everybody likes I I was
likeing what should I put that
everyone's going to like and I'm like oh
you can't go wrong with Super Mario
64 you can't go wrong with Super Mario
thank you for the five
gift you're too
kind thank you so much everybody say
thank you if you you're surprised about
that you're not you can there's no way
you can't be surprised about that I
think it's hard for the internet to do
things that surprise me what I do think
is interesting is Twitch is a platform
that recently banned gambling or
gambling adverts or anyone who gambles
on stream because they said it's bad for
a lot of the viewers and their mindset
and stuff and yet here they have sex
workers who are promoting their only
fans basically driving people to their
subscription Based Services by doing
these streams now twitch at its
Inception was mostly gaming related
stuff over time it's changed to like IRL
things or a little bit more but now they
just got full on like the whole just
jumping in here and siphoning on these
dud it used to be I had to pretend to
play video games now I don't even got to
pretend I just play the [__] footage
and then I I move my
tatas just you know what I'm saying oh
that kind of feels good but I move these
and they giving me money do you guys
ever think about why do so many of these
corn
Stars why do so many of them go on
Twitch specifically
they don't game they have little to no
interest in gaming why are they choosing
this platform specifically to advertise
themselves it's called
bait I I suspect and this is my honest
op opinion it's just because the
audience is easy yeah it is these are
people who are not used to interacting
with women of this nature yeah so they
go to these PL feain some interest they
don't even play the video game they just
[__] pop it up in the rightand
corner and then they start taking these
people's cheddar because these people
are so enamored by these women they
simping like crazy yeah it's called you
don't see half of these women never
spend any time on YouTube why the
audience is completely different the
YouTube algorithm doesn't allow for them
to just have zero and they're going to
make money so they have to actually do
something so why are they popping off on
Twitch because the discoverability to a
a population that's easily going to be
siphoned from is rarely available the
lengths that men go to because of their
loneliness or their obsession with these
l ladies is unhealthy it's like that
dude who followed Ruby Rose and was
hting her just to be like was the the
the depth of the Paras socialness and
how depraved they can be is
substantially higher with these ladies
when it comes to and then ladies know
that's why they go to this platform but
the thing is I wouldn't call it
siphoning these men cuz these men are
growing up and they know what the [__]
they're doing okay siphoning it's like I
would siphon someone if uh like I'm I'm
taking advantage of a hly person or
whatever or not like these is are
presting adults they know they giving
away their money the reason why I I I
don't like the term is because it takes
away a lot of the accountability the
accountability of these guys have it's
like uh it's like s is just like they
didn't know what was going on and it
just happened to me and then that person
just took everything away it's just like
it sounds like fraud and it's not fraud
it's not what it is when you siphon
someone is that you're doing some
intricate [__] just to get out the
person and take all their [__] I'm not
saying that they don't have any agency
or they don't have any culpability in
this okay but very much like gambling
where is your own we can say that these
are Vice that are highly addictive if
you explain it like that then fine we
agree yeah yeah yeah I'm not sitting
here to be like oh my God these poor
guys this and that I I agree with you
good then we good I agree with you then
we good here's the thing you and I as
creators we could C money out of our fan
base and in doing it ways that's not
even illegal M doesn't change the fact
that it's wrong yeah it doesn't you know
so on Wednesday you could twerk a little
twitch issued a lengthy adult content
policy update to allow previously
prohibited sexually themed content
including deliberately highlighting the
boobs ass pelvic region erotic dances
that involve disrobing if it's not in a
club strip teas if it's not in a club
okay so you don't want all them uh clubs
to start streaming right so that was on
Wednesday yeah on Friday they reversed
that new policy oh reverse yes one hop
one time bam one hop time bam cha cha
real slow
up to the left right foot now y'all B
right for right y'all everybody clap
your
hand how low can you go can you go down
L can you take it to the floor how low
can you
go bro bro bro that was probably my
favorite part about going to family
function once they played that [__]
you can Dan SP that [__] up to
the to the Y you that was me that was me
I used to used to [__] up the Cuban
Shuffle youed to [__] it
up I was super extra yeah by the halfway
like yo is this guy in a [__] Siara
music video chill out hey it was yeah
yeah a bunch of people being like what
what the [__] is going on those who know
no you're not cultured or you're from
Europe and somewhere else it's okay JZ
okay for people who know they
know guys look up the Cupid Shuffle post
comments I but preent you there don't
don't we have a video about that we did
make a video back then about that yeah
it's still up on Instagram it's not Up
On You by the way all the people like
where are your kitty pictures are I
already have it up on my Instagram it's
been there since I said it was going to
happen I don't know if preach put up his
children's no you said you would I I no
you said we said we would you said we
and you nodded no you said we yo Beach
is so slimy bro let them see you as a
baby let them see your baby pictures
that's that's cringe let let let them
see your baby pictures we agreed when we
hit 2 million we would show them no you
agreed wow preach is the one who Li I
post
them maybe one day we'll show you guys
kid pictures maybe maybe maybe 2 million
2 million Subs make sure you sub yeah
that's like three if we get to 2 million
remind us and I we I we'll do something
with the away yeah we getting there we
getting there we we've been growing this
month anyways leave your comments below
I post you lie all the time y'all want
to see me when I was cute as a kid you
not cute I saw that picture listen
forehead all day yeah forehead all day
God damn youall can see the origins from
when the forehead expanded turned into a
from a country to a
continent yay this is penio right there
P yeah yeah was Atlantis at first and
then came up [__] surfaced okay y'all
can go see the origins now okay back to
this mere days after twitch updated its
content Pol policy to permit certain
kinds of sexual content the platform has
withdrawn the portion of the policy
permitting artistic nudity effective
today we are rolling back the artistic
nudity change moving forward depictions
of real are fictional won't be allowed
on Twitch regardless of the media some
people have made all kinds of takes I've
heard people saying well you know on
Twitch they've been having discussions I
think that was uh asmin gold said they
on Twitch they have discussions that no
way shaped perform for children the
platform was never for children so I
welcome these new changes they're a w
okay some people are saying no when I go
to Twitch there should be none of the
gambling stuff there should be none of
nudy stuff which I probably fall more in
line with and I think for me it's just
the mindset like a platform is for
something when you go and there's a
bunch of other [__] that has nothing to
do with it it attracts the right wrong
kind of people it changes the whole
ecosystem of how the thing works so it's
I understand both sides to me I lean
more towards the the latter than the
former
because I always saw twitch as the
gaming thing sure there was like some
people who just had discussions but
mostly that was always what it was for
and over the years The Branding of it
substantially changed some people say
that's for the better me personally I
think if your platform really doesn't
have like a specific purpose or if it
loses its idea of branding then a lot of
people feel disenfranchised with it and
don't feel like it's for them so I'm
like why would I go to twitch when I
could just go to YouTube mhm since they
are the ones who do everything like
twitch doesn't seem to have that kind of
purpose for me and also once you have
the whole movie sub then it attracts a
really weird percentage of the
population can some of these platform is
going to be about go back to being about
video games you know is that POS there's
always going to be the people that going
to take advantage and there's always
going to be the sex industry all right
it's always true always they're going to
be like oh yeah there's people there and
it's wored you know why cuz even I went
to go look up this girl and find out who
she was and come to find out she got a
corn videos everywhere I'm like if you
can get me to watch that [__] I'll never
pay for it but if you get me to watch it
you can get a lot of people to 100% so
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below I'll link their only fans
if you guys want to go check it out for
yourselves nerds okay so wow all right
what no cuz I I could I I canot say that
whenever I said that some [__] like that
I got some Flack from you but you could
say it no I can say it when it's
accurate you can say it when it's
accurate too you can say anything is
nerds no yeah no Never No I say it when
there's nerd things like what give me an
example what's one time you said nerd
things and I went when I said that uh
gun owners can be nerds gun gun gun gun
ownership when you go in gun ownership
and you go into these Realms it's a I
said it's a different kind of nerds it's
a nerds that's just and just
specifically proficient about that and
of course you just debated like well no
that's a geek a nerd is something
different yeah it is different okay
what's the difference between a nerd
to me it's like extreme generally a lot
of antisocial Behavior it's also doing
and engaging in a hobby that most
Society doesn't think is cool or
desirable so those are just some of the
criterias most of the society think guns
are desirable look at the Republican
party they [__] love guns you easily
find you go to the South everybody loves
guns you know like if you're a a dude
who's really into guns it's not
inherently seen as a bad thing or really
like nerdy or whatever it is there are
some antisocial people who are really
into guns but the popularity of guns in
especially in America is huge it's not a
niche thing it's not like a underbelly
thing at all sometimes when you hear
them it's really oh my God you got the
Ben M4 I seen in the boovie done Wick 14
times it's like God damn you know a lot
about this [__] you got oh you got the
extal stock you got like yeah you're a
bit nerdy you're not
geeky borderline yeah I don't think
obsession with the Hobbies is nerdy I
think I think I think then I got to you
my definitions of things yeah like let's
say somebody was like really obsessed
with cooking and food like would I call
them a food nerd like I I think then if
you do that you just means like
someone's really obsessed with a hobby
then you're a stock nerd because you
spend all days researching stocks and
then making millions of dollars then
like the word nerd has lost a lot of the
social aspect got you so they what I'm
referring as nerds are actually Geeks
yeah are people like really invested
into something they're geeking out on
this you know when you say you're
geeking out on something I never said
like you're really obsessed or you're
really invested into that thing nerd
nerd them to me it's like people who do
like you know LARPing that's nerd
[__] I don't care who you are if the cop
says he's into LARPing [__]
going to laugh at him yeah cop say into
guns people like okay right there's no
connotation socially that's got got got
at least that's how I see got but that's
just me I think you got I think you got
a valid point what what the [__] was
that antlers
me cuz you remember growing up subject
when we were growing up when people used
to call people nurs what were they
always talking about computer scientist
[__] who did Dungeons and
Dragons people play magic The Gather
right and like I'm going to be honest
with you you just couldn't say that [__]
to women and then be seen as cool you
could say that [__] in public and be
seen as
cool nowadays the whole perception of
nerds has changed slowly over time
especially as like these [__] Revenge
of the Nerds have been making so much
money yeah but growing up nerd [__] was
like you played RPGs like here's an
example not all video games is nerd [__]
no like there's some main stream ones
like Call of Duty that's not not nerd
[__] right FIFA that's not nerd [__]
[__] that's just like so even the
perception Final Fantasy n [__] yeah
yeah like even other Gamers be like N I
don't do that yeah I don't do
that what are you playing N I don't do
that uh Final Fantasy 34 like some point
yeah games has changed it's supposed to
be final guys games have changed
remember remember cell phone games yeah
that changed too now it's so mainstream
everybody's doing it but if you ask that
person are you a gamer even though they
spend hours playing this [__] cell
phone dog [__] they would never call
themselves that true right gotcha so I
think that's like the main difference
but you you you geek out over
motorcycles and and
guns bang bang and vom vroom I mad at
you most people see that's cool
uh sure sure sure when I talk yeah when
you talk about motorcycles I see them oh
you got a high booa you got a high hey
you got AOA bro a booy whatever they
call it yeah a booy yeah yeah e e i n p
d e s d you know yeah yeah no yeah yeah
was good I know I know I know like yeah
motorcycle is not it's definitely not
nerds cuz yeah you people light up when
they see I got a booa People light up
when they see I got you know other
things and stuff you know what I mean
but yeah man big
engines Motors and stuff yeah that's me
I think in a couple years it might even
get to the point where even gaming as a
whole is not seeing as nerdy has it
become it's less and less more less and
less I agre I think on top of that when
you people can people get more
interested in it when they can make
money like if you say oh what do you do
for I'm a gamer yeah e yeah I just like
last week I was in Cora for this big
tournament we won how much you win a
million dollars wait what like so it
sounds to be more appealing when there's
travels and where there's money yeah
yeah so the funny thing is like some of
the best people who are good at these
games still look like the most nerdy
stereotypical thing you can imagine like
glasses B Cuts [__] like that but um the
perception is definitely changing you
know they either star to call them
Esports athletes and stuff like that
they changing a lot they changing the
perception a lot over time yeah so
that's good to see I think that I think
that'll probably be good for everyone
I'm just yeah what's up uncool doesn't
Dragon still for [__] Supreme nerds
like Warhammer bro I can't tell people I
do that [__] without people be like
excuse me what's that and every time I
have to explain that I just start
rolling my eyes like don't worry yeah
cuz you know it's nerd it is it is first
off they need to change the [__] name
there's I don't know why it's called
Dungeons and Dragons there's no Dungeons
and no dragons sometimes it's rare most
9% of what should it be
called nerds and
[__] let me play a game with Nerds and
[__] it it's really just a lot of role
playing right with like fantasy elements
okay so
sex I be creating Miniatures and
everything oh yeah the way I the way my
body
changed just when I talk about it I have
to a Golem yeah but yeah Warhammer is
another Beast that I don't even like
that's that's Elite
nerd the ones who do the tabletop
tabletop is the video games no the video
games are are super mainstream now yeah
yeah yeah people play they love playing
the video you against a million aliens
just slicing [__] up that's dope yeah
but the tabletop thing I used to love
that [__] as a kid what I couldn't
afford anything but I used to love going
there and pretending cuz like you want
to get one miniature it's like 45 bucks
so expensive
walk around and I suck at painting so
you imagine my hand like that's actually
the only time in my life I ever stole
from a store and I never sto
again like you know how stupid I am
imagine stealing some shitty ass tyranid
miniature okay and it's like you don't
have enough for an army so all you did
was just steal this little thing then I
had to go buy the glue I had to go buy
the paint stuff then I had to go buy the
everything you stupid and then I [__]
it up so there was you stole
work I'm so done you stole I never sto
that was the last time I ever stole as a
kid let me steal that [__] bring more
work at home now I got to sit down [__]
is so cool wow it is cool it is really
cool when you saw people design whole
ass armies like You' be like oh
wow I used to do um models of uh plane
models when I was in Air Force Cadets
okay right you just put them together
you have to paint them accordingly that
was you have to get the right paint and
the right paint number for the right
yeah that was crazy it was fun it's fun
if you're good at it it's fun I started
doing a bit of arts and crafts and I
suck at it but I enjoy the process n
[__] yeah absolutely um but as far as
the twitch thing
goes I just think the only thing that
really fascinated me throughout this
whole process was the getting rid of the
gambling but allowing this [__] and now
you're seeing a bit of public pressure
and that's the only time they cave on
this stuff and I think that's most of
these platforms like you said in the
last video you what you said in the last
video but you were just like wherever
the money goes that's where these people
then wherever the money goes that's
where people are going to go that's it's
100% it's a money thing if they get
siphon they will [__] there you go let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below you want to hear from
you what's up here for today